hello I'm joined now from Saudi Arabia
by Jake Paul Jake how are you
I'm good man it's been a it's been a
long day
um good to good to speak to you I know I
seen you clown Tommy Fury so please go
easy on me bro please go easy I actually
while I was waiting to interview I
watched you guys doing a thing together
quite interesting the body language
because both of you have a lot to lose
on Sunday night don't you're both
unbeaten a lot of Pride at stake a lot
of Legacy at stake here how are you
feeling about that
I love it man I love big moments I love
the high stakes this is what I came into
this sport to do is to put on big
pay-per-views big events and I'm putting
it all on the line the bigger the risk
the bigger the reward
um and there's a lot like you said on
the line it's UK versus us it's the
furies versus the Pauls and I have to go
out there and prove that I could beat a
professional boxer because that's been
the number one criticism of my career so
far so I'm super excited for this I want
to go back to before you started boxing
briefly because I'm fascinated about you
and your brother I've got three sons in
their 20s all of whom have followed both
of you for many years and have wanted me
to interview you for many years actually
you were both 10 and 12 living in Ohio
your dad was in real estate your mum was
a nurse and you get given a video camera
and you guys start just mucking around
with a video camera could you have ever
imagined that within 15 years you would
become two of the biggest internet stars
in the world
definitely not my friend uh this whole
journey has been absolutely surreal to
me it still doesn't make any sense I
feel like I'm living in a dream on a
day-to-day basis but we just have these
imaginations and are super creative and
we're willing to put in the work to
achieve our dreams and to achieve our
goals but that's part of my inspiration
of what drives me every single day is to
prove to other 10 and 12 year olds out
there that you know if you start
something if you create a hobby for
yourself if you work hard you can come
from a small town like me and and uh you
you can really make big things happen in
life did you have a dream you guys when
you were young about how this might play
out or did you just think you know what
we're just going to go for it because
I've seen you talk about you've got to
take risks right you just have to go for
stuff and then stuff happens so has this
all been almost an accidental journey to
where you've got to or did you have a
game plan
yeah look at first there was sort of a
whirlwind and we were just taking it day
by day video by video but when we
started to make serious money when we
were 16 17 years old we realized that
this could be a legitimate business and
so we had uh you know we had two options
do we stay in Ohio and keep making these
videos or do we move to Los Angeles and
go for it and try to become actors get
more involved in business collaborate
with the other big YouTubers and viners
at the time and the choice we made was
go to La and our parents supported us in
that decision and there we were you know
months later 17 and 19 years old in Los
Angeles I didn't know what a manager was
I didn't know what an agent was I didn't
even know what a lawyer did I had no
idea what I was getting myself into but
just showed up every single day and went
on tons and tons of auditions and kept
on making videos and before you know it
I booked a role on Disney Channel and
the videos kept going viral and one
thing led to another how much money have
you made
a lot a lot I don't I don't know it gets
to a point where you make so much that
you don't even count it anymore
um
so yeah I don't really know you don't
know how much money you've made I find
that hard to believe Jay you strike me
as somebody who knows exactly how much
money you've made
I I promise you Piers Morgan I have I
have no idea I make money lump sums
residuals Investments Equity exits of
companies
so the the net worth is always going up
and down but you know even moving with
the markets and such but
um I mean it when I say like I I you
stop paying attention at some point and
to me you know the money is great but I
I really love boxing and this is what I
was put on Earth to do and when I first
started out I wasn't getting paid like I
am getting paid now to box all these
guys
you know this is this is as of two three
years ago where the the Forbes list and
all this stuff started coming in from
this sport so
um I would be doing this regardless of
of the money I I I believe you but I
also know that you've you and your
brother are both exhibited a rare talent
for making a ton of cash and you are
influencers first I guess was what made
you what you were you're now a
professional boxer
there seemed to be a moment where you
were making all the money from the
YouTube stuff but it wasn't enough that
for you mentally you wanted to push
yourself in a different way unboxing
gave you that Escape Route perhaps from
the kind of Road you were going on what
was it about boxing that you think
really ignited that fire inside you
yeah look it was the routine the the
discipline
um the passion the challenge I wasn't
challenged anymore in YouTube I set a
goal to become the biggest daily vlogger
on YouTube I accomplished that goal I
was getting 15 million views a day and I
was tired of it I wasn't creatively
expressing myself properly I wanted to
move on to the next thing YouTube was
Banning everyone off their platform if
you swear in all types of crazy new
rules and limitations and I saw this I
saw that as a dead end and during that
time I I stumbled across boxing and it
took me back to my roots people forget
that I was a state wrestler a state
lacrosse player State football player
and so I really got back to my first
Dream which was to to be a professional
athlete
um and everything clicked when I got
into that boxing gym and I finally felt
at home and I was able to
mature through that process and figure
out who I truly was as a man so I needed
boxing
um and it sounds like the typical boxing
story but that's why there's so many
movies about it man because you hear it
time and time again and
um
the boxing the the boxing world and all
of that saved me for sure it's the
difference between your previous life
and this one that when you were a
YouTube influencer and that was how you
made your money and your Fame that a lot
of it could be very trivial you were
known for pranks you were known for
taking very little very seriously but
they're a very thing few things in life
more serious than getting into a ring to
fight another professional boxer where
actually your life could be at stake it
they couldn't be really two more
different things
no it's facts man and
um we don't take that lightly you know I
I know how serious of a sport this is I
know it's the hardest sport in the world
it's the hardest thing I've ever done
but something about that makes me rise
to the occasion and like you said
they're they're really Polar Opposites
you know waking up as a YouTuber every
day just wake up and do whatever it is
that you're gonna do come up with an
idea this is like a set regimen with the
team day in and day out it's it's very
professional very difficult
um but man I'm just obsessed with it
you've called out a lot of famous
fighters from Conor McGregor
to others
um why do you do that and is it just to
provoke them do you want to be in that
orbit is it to get clicks is it to get
money what is it
no man it's it's because I really want
to fight them and that's what I've
proven when I first called these people
out everyone thought I was crazy I'm
definitely a slightly crazy a little bit
but they didn't think that was actually
possible for these fights to happen and
in less than three years I've taken on
some of the biggest names in the sport
some Combat Sports Legends
um and so to me I always saw the vision
I always saw the game plan I always knew
what I was capable of and I think at
some points I was biting off more than I
could chew with calling out these guys
but my skill has quickly caught up to
um to be able to actually go in there
and beat some of these guys and I think
it's to a point now where when I called
out Conor McGregor everyone thought I
was crazy and now I guarantee you he
won't ever box me because I would beat
him and he knows that if I could be
Anderson Silva who's bigger stronger
faster better Striker than a smaller guy
and Conor McGregor is not going to want
to fight me
let me ask you about the fight on on
Sunday you're up against a guy like I
said he's unbeat there's a lot a lot of
stake here it's a proper fight now I
mean all the criticism you've taken that
you haven't had a proper fight against a
a sort of lifelong professional boxer
that criticism ends on Sunday night do
you have any doubt I hear you guys have
agreed now whoever wins takes all the
money and that's a lot of money you only
10 million dollars have you got any
doubt in your head right now that you
will win and that you may win by
knockout
no I don't I'm confident in my
preparation you know
um anything can happen in a boxing match
but you work to make those things not
happen
um and he just doesn't have the power
the capabilities to to do anything to be
able to defeat me and that's why I'm
willing to put my money where my mouth
is because talk is cheap and that's why
I'm putting it on the line and Sunday
night you're going to see me knock this
guy out be there pay-per-view pull up
Piers Morgan thank you bro for having me
final question
would you ever fight your brother
I don't know it depends what day you ask
me but
I don't know if it'll ever happen man we
could fantasize about it uh but who
would win who knows I think it could be
really interesting I would win I would
win and that's
that's the tough part is if he's okay
with being the older brother that loses
then I would do the fight but I just
don't know if he's going to be okay you
know this is how my younger brothers
talk about me
and I still beat them at arm wrestling
well
um
good for you pierce
actually the one thing I was going to
mention to you I know you're the king of
the internet and you've got 20 million
followers on Instagram but I just
checked on Twitter to see how you're
doing on that you only have four and a
half million followers on Twitter I've
got 8.4 million what does that make me
then
your your world famous Pierce and I
think I think you need to Bro tag me
like you gotta tweet me tag me bro I
need some help there on Twitter
you know what Jake because I like you
because you give me an uncensored
interview I'm actually going to help you
out and get your following up a bit I'm
worried about you languishing down in
the formulas you know you need to get
that number up thank you bro hey good
luck on somebody follow me on Twitter at
Jake Paul Jake Paul the five million on
Twitter thank you he needs it he needs
help to get anywhere near me my friend
Cristiano Ronaldo is out in Saudi do you
think he's going to come to the fire
that's what the rumors are saying man
and
um I think Tommy's going to be his
masseuse after this like you said
Ronaldo is
nothing I think one of the greatest work
ethics of any athlete that's ever played
any sport at all do you look at someone
like him and see a role model but
does he have the greatest masseuse Tommy
Fury Fury
I just came up in that category I would
pay good money to see Tommy be your
message Hey Jake thank you very much for
your time I appreciate it thank you
thank you guys all the best
well a quick update uh to that uh end of
that conversation Cristiano Ronaldo has
just told me he's going to the fight on
Sunday and he thinks he's going to be a
great fight which many people do so
there we are uh you can listen to the
Jake Paul and Tommy Fury fight live and
for free this Sunday on talksport you
download the app you listen on dab or
you go to talksport.com